Alex what separates working professional
actors from those waiting tables what
where is that point where someone
crosses over I don't know I don't know
because you can have I drove a taxi I I
was an okay actor this is it's a very
difficult question to answer because a
person waiting tables very well could be
a working actor I think the only
difference between them is that one is
working the other one is it and the
reason why is not definable unless
because if the work you leave man
waiting tables has no agent no
opportunity no nothing that's the
difference
I mean opportunity is all in this
business when your chance in that room
presents itself you either take it or
you do not and that either becomes your
job or it doesn't that's the only power
you have that line between action and
cut or start of audition and not is the
only place you have any control outside
of that the yeah it's I think a matter
of opportunity and and and a matter of
talent and what you do and when you're
given the opportunity from your
bird's-eye view why would you say many
fail at being working actors in LA from
what you've observed now that you have
this new vision from stepping away and
less emotion being time welcome from the
people that I have seen that have gone
on to become probably you know is an
engrossment in what they do a complete
the people that I have seen and learn
from and met in this business that have
gone on to do some real substantial
things one of the common threads that I
have seen in all of them is in that
preliminary first few years they went at
it like their life depended on it
they went after it like their life like
like if they didn't they were going to
die or they weren't gonna there's
nothing else to do but to do this day
and night I want this and I'm driven
and I'm passionate and I love it and I
get into it and that whether that means
you're going to make it or not I don't
know for sure but I certainly notice
that that's a common thread amongst the
people I have met that have become
successful
you